bonjour et bienvenue de nouveau pour ces
quarts de finale championnat du monde
d'échecs deux parties rapides à cannes
avec stéphane laborde et robert james
fontaine bonjour robert bonjour pourquoi
tu l'avais robert james et bien c'est
parce que c'est son deuxième prénom et
c'est également celui de bobby fischer
robert james fischer donc et c'était un
prénom prédestiné robert et oui
peut-être sans doute en tout cas nous
sommes ici pour regarder le beau match
adams contre pôle gare ils ont fait nul
dans la première partie assez laborieux
assez laborieuse puisque les deux
joueurs n'arrivaient pas à mettre le feu
à l'échiquier donc tout d'abord une
précision kasparov s'est qualifié
facilement entre guillemets en bâton
glacé à quatre chefs dans la deuxième
partie très belle partie d'attac
kasparov était content vlad un peu
déprimé un peu déçu il pensait avoir
fait des fautes dans cette partie il en
a effectivement fait mais c'est pas
grave donc kasparov qualifié deuxième
partie etienne bacrot n'a pas résisté à
yves gallimard ier flop pitoyable russe
louis etienne a fait nul il y avait un
point de plus dans une finale n'a pas su
que ne s'était pas assez suffisant pour
un pour gagner donc il éliminé de la
compétition
éliminé le français est donc il ne reste
plus aucun français
ils sont tous les deux été éliminés dès
les quarts de finale alors maintenant
nous allons commenter adams polgar le
vainqueur de ce match jouera bach hayef
donc tout est possible michael adams à
l'eiblen à noter qu'avec les blancs il
est pénible
il est pénible et
une joute c'est parti à fond dans mon
avis ça va être une autre
notre envergure que la partie précédente
la crise joue beaucoup plus agressif et
oui tout à fait donc ça risque d'être
intéressant très intéressant cette
partie adams contre j'ai dit polgar
l'autre partie s'est écrite choc contre
gourévitch avec un bandage son avantage
gourévitch puisqu'il a gagné la première
le joueur belge surmotivé et champion du
monde en titre
tout à fait donc voilà
alors que la semi rapide nous sommes à
l'écran eh oui donc il y à robert qui va
se lever à chaque coin leigh voilà qui
arrivait sur un quai sont un peu légers
d'ailleurs on peut tous se lever nous on
pourra tous nous voir voilà donc
stéphane laborde repères centaines et
edward longe c'est moi rouge avec
lunettes bleues voilà tout à fait donc
des lois qui gasquet comme d'un tome il
ya odyssée de l'espace et oui il faut ce
qu'il faut pour ressembler à nos idoles
donc thierry roland et jean michel
larqué que nous saluons au passage voilà
tout à fait alors maintenant on va
peut-être regarder les plans de la salle
parce que tout ça est sympa mais ne fait
pas avancer le schmilblick
voilà on attend que nick reprennent un
plan plus large
tu lis que s'est évidemment dit voilà
notre cadreur choc alors choc qui est
venu ici puisqu'on nous sommes six un
cadreur un réalisateur monteur d'un
preneur de son directeur d'opérations
directeur d'opération est tout à fait il
s'agit qui est parti qui a laissé sa
place et n 7 avec robert qui nous
rejoint voilà tout à fait lors les
joueurs commençaient entrées en salles
en terre voilà nous voyons gritche look
gris tchouk qui est râlant contre j'ai
dit aux gars ils se servent avant tout à
fait adapté pour le gard adams et pour
le gars qui s'installe adam ce que nous
avons vu juste avant la partie qui est
toujours très très cool
il est venu d'ailleurs avec sa femme qui
s'appelle tara qui est tout à fait
charmante
c'est sûr et là il va jouer contre
judith judit polgar la reine de
l'échappée
comment la reine de l'esha pouey
puisqu'elle s'échappe tout le temps
alors les pendules vont bientôt être
mises en route on voit passer notre ami
larbitre voilà
la michael adams très concentré le calme
avant la tempête a donc un photographe
se glissent sur l'image il s'agit de
grégory dayori puisque c'est le
photographe de la revue europe et chaque
nous allons donc bientôt commencer très
très chaud michael adams julie polgar le
score est de un demi partout le gagnant
de cette partie sera qualifié et jouera
contre garry kasparov kasparov non
contre vivre galles hibbard yapp ni vis
ni barrière casinos en général mais
finale contre le vainqueur du match
greccio j'ai dit car elle est un peu
dans les cordes comparé à michael adams
qui est bien bien concentré ça y est
c'est parti
alors nous avons michael adams qui
jouent aux quatre comme d'habitude et
oui ça ne change pas c'est sa spécialité
j'ai dit aux gars de jouer ces 5 voilà
c'est fait une à la sicilienne
pendant qu'elle dit est roi il n'ya pas
d'aller pin ici bliss droit et b3 une
spécialité anglaise à noter que j'ai dit
polgar également employé ce genre de
système quand elle et quand elle conduit
les pièces blanches b3 l'idée c'est de
mettre le four b2 tout simplement la
meilleure formation pour les noirs
contre 7 contre ce four b2 c'est de
jouer des 6 et de 5
donc là normalement le pion à elle
directement de cette année cinq ici
c'est l'idée de b3 c'est que les noirs
doivent perdre du temps s'ils veulent
adopter cette formation alors j'ai une
peau le garage ou et b6 telle la réponse
du berger à la bergère
et oui la promène son fou sur la case
bessette une ouverture à ce niveau monte
pour fonder cette attaque et +14 michael
adams joue d2 d4
il y va ça attaque on a cru que la
sicile à ne serait pas ouverte mais elle
a été ouverte foulée cette maintenant
attaque le pion au 4 mai actuelle va ce
sans doute le défendre avec food et 3
c'est le coup logique dans cette
position peut-être qu'il peut jouer un
coup anglais est ce que mes que l'album
c'est anglais anglais serait plutôt qu'à
valider deux comme ça un petit peu
curieux on sent que les normes ne sont
pas en danger déjà puisqu'elle peut
jouer des cinq sur fenêtre en cadets 2
et ouvrir directement centre ou en tout
cas de faire pression sur le centre
alors ça c'est important comme variante
on va vous la montrer des 5
c'est l'idée de judit polgar c'est ça
robert wii et sur des simples et blanc
pourrait fermer avec 2,5 mais la sueur
le plan b 3 c'est le plan b 3 est quand
même assez affaiblissant donc michael
adams doit faire un choix dans cette
position il doit défendre son pur 4 et
je crois qu'il a choisie à bali b5 vif
enfin qu'est ce que c'est que ce coup
complètement inattendu cavani b5
sacrifice de pions y at il une
explication ont peut-être que michael
adams avait fils de pian 2 michael adams
michael adams se serait peut-être énervé
puisque nous lui avons quand même dit en
backstage juste avant la partie michael
ta première partie nous a un peu fait
chier et sur quoi il a dit oui mais il y
en a une deuxième
donc voilà peut-être que oui le feu que
en fait prendre le pion à l'air très
très risqué ici à cause du poids de 4
voilà fou prend pion aux 4 et risquer à
cause de fou et 4 qui menacera une
inclusion qui menacera une fourchette
une à 3-3 contre tours une intrusion du
cheval il faudrait un échec difficile
appareils restons sur cette position
elle est importante voilà peut-être ou
la la qu'est ce que c'est que ce plan
artistique
ah oui
voilà j'ai vite polgar en images de 13
en train de réfléchir pour rentrer bien
dans la position là il faut l'homme elle
peut jouer à 6 1 elle peut jouer à ça tu
as me suis dit rien sata 6 un coup a
mentionné un coup a mentionné mais adams
pourrait prendre directement la paire de
fou en installant son cavalier sur assis
sur des six qu'elle va dire des
sinistres rendent le fou noir ça dans le
fond de caisse noire mais à ce moment là
le pion aux quatre reprises en fin de
variantes
donc c'est un début surprenant de la
part d'un ami puisque d'habitude on ne
voit pas trop sacrifier des pions comme
ça dès l'ouverture elle est plutôt
tranquille développe ses pièces et ses
de masse et tranquillement l'adversaire
oui et là surprise il sacrifier un pion
dès l'ouverture cédait pas son style
apparemment ça gène peut guère puisque
réfléchit c'est vraiment pas dans le
style de michael adams se chercher un
chaos rapide normalement ils préfèrent
des positions qui durait on pourra jouer
17 des six points car peut-être 17 des
six
c'est un coup à envisager mais
maintenant que alam sajoo et b3 il
pourra suivre fou à 3 à l'oeuf ou sur
les quais à trois tout à fait pour
mettre la pression sur les cases noires
de judit polgar très très chaud déjà
très très chaud déjà c'est bien michael
hess crise que faire dame saint michael
est là pour le public quand même oui il
joue pour le public c'est plutôt
sympathique
nous avons maker et voilà j'ai dit tu
réfléchis en tout cas la namsa lui a
posé des problèmes dès le 5ème 6ème coup
à noter qu'hier judith a fait une
miniature si vous voulez revoir ça en
différé dans les matchs des partages des
poules qualificatives
eh bien je lui dit abattu je vois le tir
aux douze coups quand même pas mal belle
performance on lit ce qui prouve qu'on
peut gagner des parties d'échecs très
rapidement enfin la cdu semi rapide donc
ça arrive beaucoup moins souvent et
après calais b sa note j'ai dit est en
train fléchir le bilan pendule est le
suivant il reste michael adams a
réfléchi une minute et judith en et
entame sa 4e minute de réflexion une
préparation de michael adams peut-être
oui c'est possible
il a dû travailler ce fils de pions
parce que il va pas lever comme ça en
deux minutes à l'emporte-pièce donc ces
ruines annuler travailler et judith
n'ont apparemment et non j'ai dit jeudi
ne joue pas elle bloque
elle bloque judit polgar à la la c'est
un très fort joueur ce n'est que la dot
à noter que ces grandes le favori à
maintenir la dame savait que garry
kasparov
c'est le deuxième favori après dire
après kaspar après anselm est rapide il
est sam à noter que vous aurez vite
shell a terminé devant lui départage
annoncé adamski devant ces dames ce qui
est devant donc adams jouera bach y ait
demain alors que courait vite ch s'il se
qualifie jouera kasparov adams
évidemment alors on nous a un peu dit
que nous étions sexistes et machistes
c'est pas du tout vrai nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est la vérité aux échecs
c'est à dire qu'un homme se gagne c'est
à dire que adams
c'est à dire que la dame ce qui a priori
le plus fort va gagner donc nous pouvons
jeter un oeil à michail vous invite sur
la grille chucky ici courez vite chez
dodo et alexander keith choc très
talentueux il a les nerfs solides
mais après avoir perdu la première
va-t-il réussir à gagner la deuxième
avec les noirs en plus avec les doors
contrecoup revitch qui joue une anglaise
pourrait vite on le voit il est là le
fameux personnage personnage de bande
dessinée pour le garage ou et un pour le
gard à jouer cavalier à six cavaliers
sur la case à 6 qu'est-ce que prévention
prévention
c'est un coup prévention mais elle
laisse définitivement
adams prendre son fougueusement c'est
possible michael adobe ce que je vaux 5
dans cette position aussi aux cinq qui a
l'air assez fort alors normal puisque on
prendra clairement les cases noires oh
la la il semblerait que je dit soit un
peu dans la mélasse ou fou fou f4 clr
intéressant phocéen sur la tf 4 il faut
montrer la position pour montrer la
position puisque là et bien c'est très
très chaud je voudrais offrir c'est une
autre possibilité pour de michael adams
puisque super gars prend le pion 24
lecavalier a si sur un 100 m sans
défense je sais pas si une combinaison
en tout cas il peut y avoir des thèmes
il peut y avoir des thèmes tactique
gênant très gênant mais a noté que le
coup quand même qu'on attend ce le cou
aux 4 5 qui a l'air vraiment pas mal
puisque 80 menaces de venir dès 6 le fou
peut venir ans à 3 avant et donc inscrit
on installera un cavalier hyper fort
donc michael adams a déjà pris davantage
on peut le dire avec son attaque éclaire
davantage également à la pendule
puisqu'il il réfléchit que deux minutes
michael adams la cellule de jouer j'y ai
réfléchi il est surpris par le coup
kablia 6 de judith on comprend pas très
bien l'idée de guérilla 6,6 n'est
protégé à 4,7 à l'oeil peur de prendre
le pion aux quatre à noter quand même
que leur puce est de le prendre
elle aurait pu essayer mais c'était
chaud donc ici d'un autre comme on le
voit c'est michael adams en pleine
réflexion et il va peut-être jouer ou
4,5
mieux ça pourquoi parfois trois
directement si elle va nous assigne
échanger directement de fougueusement ça
peut aussi faire très mal
qu'est ce que tu en penses ses fans et
bien effectivement non moins le plan
avait que 5 et faut être fou à 3 me
paraît assez fort c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai judit polgar elle a l'air un
petit peu contrarié un petit peu
contrarié c'est vrai un petit peu
abasourdi c'est vrai que michael adams
normalement c'est le joueur qui joue
tranquillement calmement sur le long
terme et la up
il les a envoyés - à chaque fois qu'il a
joué fou à 3 ou four b2 autre innovation
il a déjà joué un coup de fouet qui
avait dit un c3 qui descend
tranquillement 1,4 et menace vraiment
kabylité six échecs maintenant alors
pourquoi indique amélie un c3 est une
bonne question stéphane c'est parce que
les deux cavaliers peuvent aller en c3
le cavaly b5 et caribéens
alors si on dit qu'ils avaient dépensé 3
et bien on ne sait pas duquel on parle
donc on dit lecavalier 1
sinon ça aurait telle autre cavalier
donc avec un dessin technique en c3
voilà comme les scènes quand ces trois
là tout à fait donc ici et juke avait
dit un c3 et il menace cavaliers des
sinistres
donc là on ne précise plus parce qu'il y
en a plus qu'un qui peut y aller et des
six échecs au roi donc qui forcerait
judith a donné son fou michael adams
prendrait donc la paire de fou et
obtiendrait une très belle position avec
domination sur quasiment mais oui on
voit mal comment je dis tu peux empêcher
maintenant cet échange s'il peut jouer
des sites a décidé si elle peut jouer
des six où il est en baisse
essayer de contrôler cette case à mes
fans à 1000 fou dame de vite se
heurterait peut-être à g iii un goût
typique de ce type de position
c'est vrai si 6e est tout à fait tout à
fait d'un v8 il y aurait sans doute le
projet de ge et trois thématiques
mais bon on ne peut pas savoir en tout
cas michael adams par son dernier coup
laisse souffler un peu judit polgar mais
il a pris l'avantagé à la pendule
ça y est ce n'est plus coup pour coup
maintenant il ya avantage pour michael
adams avantages autant davantage de
l'esprit michael adams y21 une minute à
adams contre 18 à judit polgar et oui ça
va pas être facile en jeu dit elle est
en train de réfléchir mais elle a pas
l'air
elle appelle en méchante là quand même
elle a l'air un peu gentille
ça cache quelque chose
cette cache quelque chose
pas perdre inspiré du tout alors que
michael adams lui il n'a jamais l'air
inspiré mais on sent quand même là qu'il
est à fond dans sa position
c'est un des joueurs les plus
concentrées du circuit michael adams
oui ça se voit
vraiment très très fort c'est que si on
compare son attitude à celle de green
shoe qu il ya un fossé
pourquoi quand on n'a pas vu on n'a pas
vu gris choc se lever pendant sa
première partie non il n'a perdu
d'ailleurs peut-être ancienne biathlète
pas hyper alors que judith à jouer elle
a envoyé un cavalier c5
c'était ça l'idée alors maintenant
question que se passe-t-il sur x 2,4 et
bien je crois que c'est la cagade c'est
un coût qui fait mal ouhlala ah oui
qu'est ce qu'elle a vu sur faut être
quatre c'est la question qu'est ce qui
se passe faut 4 qui menacera cavalli
c'est cet échec au roi
oui non plus autour c8 tout simplement
pour ses vitres le pion à cette emprise
stéphane c'est vrai ça c'est
problématique
donc qu'est ce qu'elle peut jouer sur
flu f4 on va simulescu simulation faut
être quatre ce n'est pas jouer mais
c'est possible menace
kbc 7 alors le coup proposé par
l'ordinateur c'est le ku'damm f6
s'échoue c'est chaud c'est chaud on peut
dire que c'est pour le moins curieux
ouais on n'y croit pas trop à 2606 c'est
curieux mais si ça va des reculs roi
c'est sûr avec complications donc voilà
la position judit polgar du week-end et
c5 et là on se demande pourquoi michael
adams n'a pas encore les foules 4 et
bien la réponse est simple il est en
train d'évaluer toutes les possibilités
qui peuvent aboutir après faut être
quatre mais six toiles car ça rend le
coupé trois inopérant oui mais c'est pas
très important puisque les cases des 6
et 7 sont
tout à fait sont très très importante
c'est les cases majeur c'est tout ce qui
fait l'essence de cette position c'est
ce qui fait que les blancs peuvent
prendre l'aventage peuvent gagner cette
partie et donc c'est très important pour
le titre de champion du monde qui peut
revenir mais que la dame ce qui a joué
quatre jours ff iv et voilà et voilà
prends toi ça alors à noter que là il va
y avoir un thème de matin un goût si les
normes joue cavalier en cette voie la
légimité recettes il y aurait parmi l'un
des six tout à fait gérable avoir été
enfermé le câble est centrée sur les
caisses des six floup échec et mat ce
climat aux yeux de marie lou et wii fit
et mario f4 et oui j'aurais fermé que la
dame ce sens sont connus qui ont
regretté gainsbourg qu'ils ont déjà
la menace c'est la fourchette cavaliers
des cinq en c7 et j'aurais pas dit mais
voilà vous remontre cette menace qui est
b5 échec au roi
elle va être belle victoire à prendre le
pas même si ça va jouer c'est dans son
style on est de toute façon on n'a pas
le choix et les objets je crois qu'elle
ajoute ours et vite
alors pour ses victoires ses huit ours
et 8 d'oise est vraiment phénoménal
c'est vraiment phénoménal que se
passe-t-il sur cavaliers prend pions
tout simplement
c'est la question qu'on peut se poser
peut-être date même si sûr qu'elle ait
pension mais après il y aura même des
deux tout simplement alors cavaliers
champions à 7
nous allons rester sur cette position
virtuelle qui est pression à cette
attaque la tour c'est une variante
snaith à murray a été jouée se soit
fourvoyé tout de suite dame f6 hélas la
pointe s'est simplement cavaliers pro
tour c'est vite et la p3 pas on ne
comprend pas bien ce n'est pas ça le
coup on sait ce que c'est le coup alors
dans cette place via deux mains des deux
il ya 84 aubert tendidos et ce coût d'un
f3 leurs états d'âme attaqueraient la
tour 9
et ce n'est pas si clair peut-être fou
des deux proposés par
trop beau mais ici c'est tout sauf
évident et lequel il reviendra après on
dézingue possibilité en tout cas on ne
veut pas vous embrouiller plus longtemps
tours s'est vite faire des trous et par
judit polgar michael adams réfléchi et
là donc c'est très très chaud un enjeu
pour cette position stéphane mais ça me
reculer plein soit quand même clairement
mieux
donc je dirais avantage adams alors un
petit coup d'oeil rapidement sur
gourévitch qui va boire à la bouteille
voilà qui boit de l'eau là nous avons
pris tchouk le russe entre gourévitch
l'ex russe le voit la mairie gourévitch
toujours extrêmement concentré il est
très peu nerveux aussi gourevitch c'est
donc le deuxième quart de finale et
c'est très important puisqu'il ragon
habitués le champion du monde deux
parties rapides en titre il est ici
favoris face à des azzurri la cause
qu'elle accueille la première partie il
avait battu en finale karpov je m'en
vais bien il avait battu anatoli karpov
et donc il a déclaré dans une interview
qu'il a donnée à des gones al j'ai battu
karpov
je vais battre kasparov à cannes et je
battrai krainik pour la prochaine coupe
du monde il affiche ses ambitions
il a dit ça il a dit ça il est capable
effectivement il a dit un peu en
rigolant mais enfin quand on voit jouer
ça ne nous fait on rien du tout en tout
cas ça ne fait pas rire kasparov qui est
la cible directe ravis de ces
allégations spiral chaos rawicz le belge
d'ieteren le belge alors nous on belge
d'origine russe quand même
faut rappeler ça est-ce que sk dame va
tenter de prendre ce fut là et c'est
françois pion ou alors il va la jouer
soft en essayant de défendre tout
simplement son fief quatre cavaliers c3
par beaucoup comme d'amd de maintenant
un coup comme dam des deux c'est
possible aussi de toute façon michael
adams a davantage mais je verrai plus
qu'elle va dit prends pion à cette année
michael michael on voit cavaliers prend
1,7 à la michael
on a beau je pense que si la salle de
théâtre s'écrouler autour de lui et bien
qu'il ne se rendrait pas compte
je vois bien d'écran gérant lui tomber
dessus
et bien il ne le remarquerait même pas
me concentrer et adams tout est fait
judith aussi y va quand même mais
peut-être c'est moins efficace
à la michael qui réfléchit on voit les
petits drapeaux sur le côté le drapeau
anglais pour michael et le drapeau
endroit pour judith
à noter que tous les autres tops qui
sont pas présents ici sont présents à
monaco
effectivement on l'a signalé sur le
tchat
ils sont tous partis à monaco puisqu'ils
ont des invitations qui date d'il ya
plus d'un an
donc rien à faire que la coupe du monde
allait décider a été décidé d'être
organisée à cannes il ya huit mois et
bien tout le monde avait déjà signé pour
monaco ça et ce dès que les vents dans
la journée de repos tous les beaucoup de
joueurs de monaco sont venus ici à le
regarder les parties ont notamment vu
alexei shirov effectivement alors que le
plan sur les pièces plan artistique avec
michael adams en fonte qui est là
je suis dit paul gars qui est là aussi
et là michael va jouer il va jouer d'amd
4 j'ai l'impression si je n'ai pas rêvé
oui dam des quatre dames des quatre
centrales centrale coup on coud
tranquille tranquille et il va peut-être
prépare un grand que tout simplement
c'est possible peut-être le grand roque
ou peut-être simplement le contrôle de
la case des six mais après tout le purin
cette île est pas il n'est pas pressé de
le prendre
il va il va tendre se la joue à six oui
oui puisse fixer paul bien sûr les cases
noires et il va essayer d'empêcher la le
rock le roc de poker dont qui joue
positionnelle adams plutôt que d'essayer
de prendre l'aventage matériel il nous a
souvent reproché sur les cases nous a
surpris avec ses cinquième et sixième
coup et là ça y est il redevient le
joueur positionnelle qu'on connaît
et ça va être chaud pour pas le gars
maintenant ça va être chaud pour paul
garret se décide entre le coût probable
en f 7 et 6 a7 a6 a7 a6 et a106
peut-être au fcf si c'est très
affaiblissant stéphane même si composé
on n'aime pas trop jouer ce genre de
coup et c'est vrai c'est un coût qui
paraît très affaibli sens mais qui peut
reprendre un peu le contrôle les cases
noires qui menaçe think we sa menace la
fourchette c'est le conte proposée par
un asocial que l'ordinateur mais si on
n'y croit pas un instant puisque il
pourrait s'en suivre tout simplement
cavaliers des six échecs et prendre le
fameux fou de cases noires de judit
polgar oui on voit qu'elle bouge ses
jambes
on voit le pied de judith ici oui elle
est nerveuse très jolis pieds ailés
nerveuse et lui adams est tranquille
alors qu'est ce qu'elle va nous préparer
ici à cette a6 a l'air vraiment de
perdre un temps dans cette position il
faudrait qu'elle essaie de développer
ces pièces et d'un peu d'enflammer tout
ça convainc pas trop commun parce que si
elle joue le fou f8 sur la case de cette
si on peut voir la position à la jouer à
la joue et stéphane elle a joué elle a
joué cavalier si c'est oui la jolie
cavalière même si elle essaie de
développer ces pièces mais pression sur
quatre marques
oui ça augmente la pression sur le cas
puisque maintenant me lecavalier 6
lecavalier ccnq et le fourbe et cette
tape sur os 4 et oui pression sur quatre
elle développe ses pièces alors
maintenant adams a plusieurs
possibilités soit faire échec et
sacrifions soit jouer tout simplement eu
oui la possibilité effectivement de
jouer de 4,5 mais de 4,5
peut-être il a envie de contrôler la
casse des six avec son fou michael adams
oui tout à fait
alors que j'enlève les va jouer que va
jouer un seul peut-être f3 mais vous
fout des trois fous des trois serait pas
mal protégé le purin 4 qui a attaqué un
bon coup dans beaucoup de judit polgar
un coup surprenant mais qui a coûté
veloppement c'est tout ça peut pas être
un mauvais coup tout à fait on sort ses
pièces alors qu'il doit est de retour et
oui c'est le grand retour
c'est le grand retour michael adams ici
peu chouikha vas-y trompions à 7
on ne comprend pas trop le dernier coup
de judit polgar pieds carrés sis au
développement pourquoi est-ce que le
jouer ça alors est ce qu on a eu le
temps d'expliquer ce qui se passait sur
quels points à 7 on ne comprend pas
cavalli b5 trompions à 7
qu'est-ce qui se passe certes la tour
c'est vite la tour doit bouger et le
cavaly revient au coup d'après j'ai dit
aux gars n'ayant pas créer de menaces
avec son dernier coup qu'elle dise oui
et oui oui tout à fait c'est sûr ici ce
n'est pas évident beau judith câbles
hypron pion à 7 a l'air d'être un coup
très fort à cette ouverture de l'adams
il va le jouer michael adams d'autant
plus qu'il est bien en temps on y est
bien autant en plus ça oui et bien
autant puisqu'il reste quatorze minutes
sont faites sont à égalité aux tensions
égalité were mais il a une bonne
position
ouais alors ça va beaucoup moins vite
beaucoup moins vite qu'avant aulas alors
peut-être qu'on aura pas de matchs à des
partages en fait hein parce que si
michael gagner cette partie et que
pourrait vite se perd pas et bien
c'était femme je n'ai rien n'aura pas
dommage de départage nous n'aurons pas
de match de partage mais michael n'a pas
encore gagné la partie et ivoire beach
n'a pas encore éviter la perte
c'est très très chaud très très chose
qui est en train de se passer
judit polgar contre michael adams deux
joueurs pour une qualification en demi
finale de la coupe du monde d'échecs
si michael adams gagne et qu'il va akbar
hayat demain il jouera kasparov en
finale sans doute est il le battra ce
qui fera de lui le champion du monde de
partir bille ça veut dire le meilleur
joueur de la planète on vois pas qui
peut battre kasparov quand même de f3
été joué un coup très solide qui protège
tout simplement le plus en 4 réveiller
un coup tranquille d'adams relations il
a joué à fond la position incroyable
incroyable vraiment mais michael adams
politiques écoutent champions à 7
je le prends quand je veux je prends
quand je veux et je je me développe je
fais ce que je fais vraiment ce que je
veux et qui je fais ce que je veux avec
mes pièces tu n'auras jamais de contre
je judith f3 jeu c'est un bon outil
explose le cavalier m6 maintenant il ne
peut plus bouger ce cavalier qui tue le
foot 17 puisque il devient mal placé et
le calice et 5 n'a plus son utilité donc
en fait avec un simple coup de pions il
a neutralisé trois pièces de judit
polgar neutralisent pôle gare avec une
aisance
on est incroyable incroyable un pion
d'adams ça vaut trois pièces de judith
pêcheurs donc évidemment il a un énorme
avantage matériel
peut-être qu'il réfléchit mieux donc
c'est possible c'est possible aussi mais
enfin
par nature donc la partie n'est pas
finie alors on peut se demander si je
dis t'as pas intérêt à jouer un coup
comme des cinq voix effectivement le
relate stéphane tu as tout à fait raison
puisque des 5 c'est un coup
positionnelle sa lutte contre ce que
rêve 3 directement ce pur f3 qui tue et
toutes les pièces ennemis et bien en
jouant des cinq on obtient des chances 2
mais on peut leur faire vivre les
relations à 7
le problème c'est que sa peur du
matériel de toute manière à cette alerte
est réduit dans cette partie il faut il
faut se développer le très noir sinon on
peut on peut jamais sortir donc des cinq
a l'air très très intéressant mais
escudé sans escales dams pourra tout
simplement jouer grand roque et et
continuer c'est vrai que michael dans
cette pression peut simplement se
développer en jouant qu'on voit une
énorme avance de développement camp rock
c'est pas mal il faut en profiter
tout à fait
c'est le truc belle position de michael
adams quand même
il est en train vraiment dominé cette
partie est à noter que dans la partie
griche gourévitch bien devant 8 chez vis
tout simplement où les chocs les mieux
on voit les joueurs ici qu'on revitch a
pris un net avantage contre gottschalk
il semblerait que les nerfs du jeune
russe ne puisse pas le sauver contre
l'expérience du belge mihailovic
champion du monde sortant
on l'a suffisamment dit mais quand même
10 quand même ce pion à 7 que adams ne
prend jamais le tekken furieux pion à
sept cavaliers à 6 alors qu'est ce que
c'est que ce coup
qu'est-ce qu'elle a inventé judith
paulien elle vient de jouer tenez vous
bien qui avait laissé cinq sur les cases
à 6 et ça c'est vraiment très difficile
à comprendre il faut sortir son x 8 pour
lemaitre ans et 5
oui mais c'est une capitulation complète
puisqu'elle où j'ai trois fois la même
pièce d'ouverture ça n'existe pas et
surtout en a six surtout aussi ce que se
passe-t-il sur cabaye était six échecs
tout simplement à nous apprendre le
football garde
il laisse le plus être qu'un set je
pense qu'il n'en a pas besoin il va
simplement l'empêcher de roquet
peut-être en jouant qu'elle ait des
essais chez agf ou des six ont été pas
mal d'anglais et décider quelle idée si
c'est vrai que c'est bien vous prend et
fait des licences garde la boucherie
c'est horrible c'est horrible alors la
pauvre gars ne bouge plus
sait on en est au 10e coup et judit
polgar est complètement complètement
atomisé
c'est une boucherie cette partie
effectivement qui est des six robert
comme tu l'as dit ça a l'air plutôt pas
mal plutôt fort après fou prend on
reprend du fou et là on contrôler toutes
les cases noires
c'est vraiment une très très belle
position projet de pôle gare donc
michael adams en france est embarrassé
oui la pression pour michael adobe se
détend baradat ici l embarras du choix
il ne sait plus comment gagner oui ces
projets tic
il peut prendre un set aussi il peut
prendre un set mais ça devrait pousser 5
oui il faut pas essayer de toute façon
michael adams n'a jamais voulu prendre
ce pion à 7 soit kamel et 10,6 soit fou
des six de possibilités qui est
désagréable 6 qu'est ce qu'il a fait
cavalier dit l'autre canadien en d6 et
oui normal un tour de vis il faut
absolument prendre ce cas là c'est
obligé puisque il ya une fourchette
il a repris du fou une fort qu il faut
prendre et si ce fou prend fou des six
alors un plan pour j paul bert de rennes
d'installer un cavalier en recettes par
exemple gamaleya 6 par cavalli bébittes
cavalli
6 cabrio s'être fait trop long oui c'est
trop long mais que c'est obligé stéphane
c'est obligé cavalli b 8e
donc alors je n'y arrive pas décidément
kébé vie depuis qu'elle sait si ce qu'il
gagne un temps en attaquant la dame puis
cavaliers au set puis petit rock
salaires long mais il faut bien trouver
une solution stéphane dans cette
position est à noter qu'après le plan
cavaliers 8 a été jouée qui habitait là
j'en serais caballos est petit rock vite
n'est pas sorti puisque elle ne bougera
toujours pas à se fout des six est
vraiment extrêmement fort l'idée
vraiment fabuleux ça c'est pas facile
pour judit polgar elle risque tout
simplement de se faire virer par michael
adams autant plus que l est mal à la
pendule michael apted uras 13 minutes
jeudi à lui reste dix minutes et donc
tout ça n'est pas de très bon augure
pour la hongroise qui se fait
copieusement massacrés par michael adams
on voit judith elle a pas l'air en forme
elle a l'air plutôt en mauvais état et
contrôlent pas du tout les cases noires
à noter que toutes les pièces contrôle
que des cases blanches
le fou bessette contrôle des cases
blanches le caribéen 8 aussi le
cavaliere 6 aussi tout à fait stéphane
que y'a aucune pièce qui contrôle les
quatre mois par la dame noire c'est la
seule pièce qui ne peut pas vous gêner
elle peut pas bouger elle est
complètement fermée donc toutes les
pièces des noirs contrôler les cases
blanches et donc ça fait qu'ils
contrôlent la moitié des cases au lycée
pas suffisant parce que michael szames
celui des contrôles tout
donc il est deux fois plus fort 64e de
32 et oui
kébé 8 michael adams réfléchit
maintenant il faut trouver un côté c'est
pas facile pour passer peut-être il va
jouer g4 mcadams essentielle il faut
plutôt mettre le laurent blanc sécurité
avant de se lancer dans dans une halte
dans une attaque grand roque grand roque
par exemple camp rock c'est possible
peut-être g4 on me signer m non que
michael adams a joué il a joué dam des
quatre en d2 oui prophylaxie un don qui
se prémunit contre le coup car il sait
si ce que je dis tu vas sûrement joué
oui je n'y sois jouer à crédit si c'est
moi il ya d'alger 5
c'est ça l'idée de mettre de la valse il
est en train de passer angers 5
c'est un cauchemar cette position la
dame angers 5 et exerce une pression sur
l'option g7 s'il provoque g6 c'est fini
c'est fini c'est fini que je dit paul
car ne pourra plus jamais contrôler les
casenoves donc judit polgar doit doit
empêcher d'alger cinq mois peut-être en
jouant à 6 est ce que tu aimes c'est ça
qui est vraiment une menace puisque le
cavaly c3 est en l'air pour l'instant à
chis h6 à l'heure normale
l'alchimie salaire normal à noter que
dame g5 n'est pas forcément une menace
tout à fait oui mais ça 6 en sera une
après kabylie ces six puisque la tour
s'est vite notre voilà quand exactement
ces trois c'est le problème elle peut
pas jouer cavalier c3g dit polgar
qu'elle c6 sinon il ya d'alger 5
la punition anglaise la punition
anglaise
mais ça va être très très dur face et
douloureux surtout contre adams c'est
clair c'est pas le joueur le plus facile
michael adams
elle donnait la paire de fouet après
treize coups il semble qu hier soit tout
simplement perdante est perdante c'est
pas évident parce qu'il faut arriver à
percer comme on vous dira négligent
techniquement perdante en tout voilà
c'est ça c'est ça ne perd pas de manière
mathématique et forcé mais sur le long
terme
très très peu de chance pour judit
polgar l'adolescence elle a joué le coup
à sata 6 judith à 7 à 6 curieux comme
vous elle ne sait plus quoi faire
ouais elle veut et voilà mon analyse
mais voilà
michael adams satisfait de sa position
vous le voyez ici
alors qu'est ce qu'il envisage eh bien
il ya beaucoup de coups beaucoup de
coups forts d'apcher 5 alors annonce le
g5 n'est pas possible en revanche
peut-être tour d un toit en d1 grand
croix b2 et ensuite c'est pas mal on va
montrer cette position pour montrer les
possibilités de michael holmes elle veut
jouer b5 et b6 peut-être pour sentir
saddam alors p5 et d'appeler 6 bof bof
grand'croix b2 moi j'aimais bien le plan
consoler par stéphane g4 g5
je trouvais ça assez intéressant pour
commencer puisque le roi michael adams
est totalement en sécurité au centre de
l'échiquier
pourquoi est ce qu'il dirait pas
commencer tout de suite une attaque à la
baïonnette pour s'élancer dans avec son
fils et six et sept parties stéphane me
fait rappeler énormément la partie qu'il
avait échoué contre joël l'audi à
bordeaux en finale du grand prix de
bordeaux 2000 quand il avait tout
simplement massacré choix de l'outil en
finale avec un fou de cases noires sur
efficace comme ici jacques gauthier
n'avait rien pu faire alors que
n'oublions pas qu'ils sont quatre sur
scène et là il y à michail gourévitch le
belge la belle qui tue très très
efficace toujours verrait gourévitch les
pièces la position va vous commenter un
petit peu leurs positions
avantage gourévitch mais il semblerait
que kate show commence à trouver des
contresens et au niveau de la pendule et
bien c'est totalement équilibrée
avantage même pour coup revitch qui la
dernière fois avait gagné puisqu'il
était beaucoup mieux autant on peut
jeune chris shaw qui n'a que aidé à 17
ans qui ils s'attendent qui est très
très impressionnant
demi finaliste des championnats du monde
deux parties lentes éliminé uniquement
par shirov et bien il est en train de
souffrir à jouer au beach mail je
voulais qu'elle adopte ce voyage ou un
coup à quatre noms avant être à carla
laisse aucune chance à produire à 4
empêche b5 empêche que la dame noire de
se développer tout simplement
il est insupportable michael adams non
mais il est vraiment idée vraiment fière
ils jouent des coudes un petit coup
franc qu'il pour de gravats est rendue
exsangue 15 coups c'est à dire que voilà
le subside ces cantons tous les coups
qu'on a à jouer sont mauvais et bien ici
on se demande ce que va jouer chez dit
paul gars là lâche 6 beaucoup
à noter quand même robert un avantage
dans ce genre de pression pour les noirs
c'est ya tellement peu de coups qu'on
n'a pas trop de problèmes pour choisir
et on peut les jouer vite et on peut les
jouer assez vite donc récupérer un peu
et on peut croiser à la pendule est
proposé 1 h 6 pourquoi le gard mais
après h ici adam se joue un quelconque
oui on voit mal le prochain coup de pôle
gare tout simplement c'est clair alors
on va bien vous expliquer ça avec
l'échiquier voilà judit polgar n'a plus
de quoi jouer on voit que sur calais c6
il y a éventuellement d'alger 5
elle ne peut par ok puisque le fou
contrôler la casa fuite le food et si ce
contrôle la quasi fluide ce qui interdit
donc le rock
elle ne peut pas bouger ce qui m'a dit
m6 parce que le maître chien que ça n'a
tout simplement pas de sens le fourbe et
7 non plus le quai bélu tandis qu'elle
pouvait pas la tour s'est vite non plus
la tourache 8 non plus rafion il va
falloir je veux un coup de pions mais
sur quoi michael adams pour jouer un
coup de roi ou un coup de n'importe
quelle pièce et ça serait catastrophique
puisque ne sait plus du tout mais alors
plus du tout coiffé religieux bien elle
vient de produire un coup à mal
québec j'ai vite voilà vous voyez l'état
du drame kg fille c'est vrai que bon
cavalier vite à vue
frey 8 alors parce qu'on dit génération
cavaliers aux 7 pour ok il faut à 8 fait
sans doute sur la 8e avenue de la vidéo
7 pour grippe clinique pour ok ou alors
peut-être stéphane qu'elle se prépare
pour faciliter le travail de l'arbitré
c'est à dire qu'elle remet les pieds sur
la case de départ pour que à la fin bien
c'est simple de remettre la pression de
départ ou pas c'est la tour c 8 en 1 8es
loin n'est ce pas évident ce qui est pas
si facile donc ici net avantage pour
michael adams qu'il va continuer à
sortir ses pièces fou c4 est pressentie
bon pour l'instant il n'y a pas
davantage matériel a quand même moins ça
c'est le on peut quand même le signaler
donc c'est pas évident que j'ai dit
polygame est d'amasser pas évident et
d'aller chercher les noirs quand même
c'est une disposition
parce qu'il faut quand même avancer les
pions en donner pour faire défaut de
créer des ruptures stéphane imaginons
que ce soit kasparov qui est blanc est
ce qu'on aurait un seul doute sur le
résultat final de la partie
ouais donc c'est sûr que moi je vois
bien je reviens adams jouer h 2 h 4 h 2
h 4 tout simplement pourquoi pas voilà
on va regarder les chics et l'a
peut-être qu'il va jouer h 2 h théâtre
michael adams pour limiter les
possibilités de l'âne à la table de
génie tall garde un oeil là je fous ces
quatre à fos et 4 qui est un bon coup un
bon coup hocine qui se développe alors
il va préparer avec 4 5 1 je crois
michael adams
oui il faut bien qu'il prépare quelque
chose quand même c'est ça le problème
c'est qu'il faut quand même aller
chercher les noirs way mais ouais mais
bon je pense qu'il va y arriver et que
la dame si warocqué il en aura beaucoup
de temps de développement d' avance un
peu ça y est ça a été fait si rock
kallio s'est tu es petit rock alors la
gt2 polgar peu rauque et maintenant elle
s'exposerait à une attaque mortelle
mortal est quasiment impossible apparaît
une avancée du bélier le bélier c'est le
pion f3 le voilà le pitch trois cas vous
voyez ici en rouge qui menacerait
d'avancé donc j'ai dit que le gars est
très très ennuyée dans cette position
puisque elle ne peut plus bouger les
michael adams a joué non j'ai dit paul
garde j'avais lartilleux rock tour a des
seins tout simplement tour à des 1 1
mais c'est vraiment pas jolie la menace
directe c'est fou des six points qu'à
aider vite qu'ils viennent le brun 17
900 par année souffre ou enfin quand
même on envahirait la septième rangée
avec un gain facile
bon c'est une menace comme une autre
mais s'il faut pas prendre le cavalier
et bien ça veut dire vraiment la
position des noir et désespéré
désespérée on voit même pas on voit
aucun plan pour produire rappelons quand
même que j'ai dit pas le gars est la
reine de l'échappée ça veut dire qu'il
peut s'échapper de beaucoup de
situations c'est vrai qu'il ya on l'a vu
dans les matchs se départageant blitz
qui sont donc toujours disponibles à la
demande est bien hervé carré les c6 de
situation quasi désespérée elle va
peut-être pouvoir le refaire et c6 donc
elle se prémunit contre la menace franck
magnier puis 5 917 quand même l'option
17 n'y a plus on peut prendre le set et
prendre en 17 après falloir qu'ils se
décident macadam f4 je verrais bien mais
que la dame sont assez champion f1 le
pion au f4 f5 avec un duo de fou braqués
vers le roi
et puis les tours qui passe f4 c'est un
très bon coup que michael adams va sans
doute jouer rouach il a joué au rachat
va être vraiment tranquille il prend son
temps d'hitler moi j'ai dit paul gars tu
bouges pas eh bien voilà tu es ligoté tu
ne peux plus bouger tour vital à jouer
j'ai dit ouais pour libérer son cavalier
on s'est alors elle joue plus vite je
dit il va cinq minutes il reste six
minutes à michael adams six minutes
c'est pas beaucoup ça veut dire qu'il
peut se tromper
il faut pas qu'ils traînent trop michael
sinon six minutes quand on sème une loi
peut préparer autant par contre oui tout
à fait même si elle est allée dit côté
mais bon il faut quand même aller
chercher les noirs mais comme on l'a dit
tout à l'heure stéphane le fait d'être
ligoté nous permet de jouer plus vite
puisque on a beaucoup moins de choix
voilà le michael adams qui joue où la
bombe et non mais c'est pas très joli se
couche quand il a joué au foot est roi
fou détroit il s'y perd à la michael il
s'y perd le dernier coup de michael
adams on vous l'heureux montre au
ralenti il avait voulu dire sur la case
d3 peut-être peur de cavaliers à 5
oui bon mais alors qu'est ce qui vous
fait il veut jouer avec at-elle 5
toujours à priori quand même c'est pas
on n'en est pas sûr normal foot est roi
c'est curieux quand même c'est curieux
qui l'attendent comme ça michael adams
c'est un coup qu'on aime pas fous ces
quatre détroit enfin oui mais
on voit pas trop trop de coups pour paul
guerlain ont pas toujours pas beaucoup
trouvent pour poker oui mais là on
attend qu'elle a des goûts ça va oui
alors qu'elle a des coûts tant qu'elle a
des coups ça va une remarque stéphane
qui n'engage que toi parce que il suffit
pas d'avoir des coûts pour pouvoir s'en
sortir
non mais encore une fois faut aller
chercher les noirs c'est pas si facile
non moi je ne le vois pas là je vois
bien une position la position se
terminer sur une partie nulle moi alors
je veux bien prendre le pari de même si
les noirs sont ligotées les blancs sont
quand même à distance
il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas d'autre
véritable rupture je pense que la seule
chose qui pourrait sauver judit polgar
c'est une faute de mathieu la dame s'en
aille note est une arnaque une arnaque
tactique à noter qu'elle arnaquer
beaucoup de partis jeudi première donc
s'il ya quelque chose à voir
elle va le voir maintenant effectivement
il faut que michael adams se trompe
c'est quand même la chose numéro un
alors à la joue et un camé g6 l'autre
cavaliers sur laquelle j'ai six très
bien mais rien n'a été jouée f4 failli
l'envoi michael adams il en cinq sets il
s'agit de virer mais on donne encore et
encore la case des sacs après f5 après
fc un axe f6 peut-être à elle signé
lacazette 4 qui est perdu et 5 et 6
pourquoi pas et oui 5ème sa cavale jouer
cavalier f4 pour essayer de se libérer
et c'est elle
5c'est f5 validé cinq mais c'est
vraiment c'est de pire en pire
ça va mal pour judit polgar ça va très
très mal qui est ce qu'elle peut faire
y a pas joué encore michael adams il
réfléchit dans cette position pas si
facile
est-ce qu'il va prendre en 5 ou est-ce
qu'il va jouer f5
c'est la question il a joué avec 5 et
les joies f5 normal judit polgar fait
cavalière cas normal aussi le seul coup
qui peut lui permettre de se prémunir
contre m6 alors que l'ordinateur annonce
égal à l'ordinateur annonce égale
incroyable incroyable
bah oui c'est pas si simple peut être
une faute d'évaluation de l'ordinateur
je ne sais pas chez trois peut-être joué
par michael adams mais ça ramènerait le
fou bessette
il semblerait que match aller et jouets
est légèrement apprécié légèrement
trésor mais c'est pas si facile
enfin les quand même beaucoup mieux
armés c'est pas si facile à jouer
s'il a joué mais peut-être que qu'il y
aller un peu léger en effet il a joué
cavalier de il veut changer ce cavalier
la seule pièce active des noirs c'est
normal
pour le gars va prendre soin le cavalier
de soi le foin des 3
et peut-être damev si c'est possible
également essayé de déloger sous des 600
la pression que les douars se déplie là
oui oui et non je n'ai plus le flou des
six blocs toujours bien la position
ça y est cavalier prend des trois dames
prend et cavaliers des 4 elle essaie
d'en fumer elle essaie d'en fumer adams
c'est parti cavalli t4 et oui c'est pas
qu'est ce qui se passe au coeur les
points cavaliers suis 2e 5
oui ça va venir est un peu le foot case
de fougasses blanc joaillier m6 à 9,6
alors de calmer un m6 a été joué olala
ça chauffe un f6
voilà s'est adjugé 3
ah oui il faut absolument empêcher il
faut prendre réussissent à leur tour
aussi ça a été joué et oui vous voyez un
second examen incroyable fou et 7 non
mais ça y est je crois que là ça tourne
au vert va devoir donner la qualité mais
non et ça c'est ça perdrait tout de
suite ça pas sûr que je vous nomme c7
wemmel vasciller mater sur 4 noir
stéphane non non on va montrer cette
seul coup tout reprendre cette seule
cour d'alger trois dames g5 damage six
essais map
il faut jouer et on procède à 9 8 a été
jouée ou d'un 8 que ce qu'est ce qu'elle
a vu qu'est ce qu'elle a vu robert n'a
rien vu elle a rien vu ça doit être ça
dan gilroy il va jouer michael adams
d'alger 3 c ce coup qui menacent matt
angers7
ensuite la dame pourra monter ici puis
en hausse 6 et seimat
qu'est ce qu'elle a vu je tiens à vous
seul défense et loi ce sera de mettre
laurent n'a fuité l'adamant g8 c'est pas
joli mais c'est la seule défense ouais
mais il va comme je devais 3 michael
adams à y est c'est fait g6 elle lâche
de judit polgar et maintenant comment ça
se passe je pense qu'il va prendre le
cavalier des quatre se passe là il faut
rester sur la position puisque les
joueurs n'ont plus beaucoup de temps il
ya trois minutes qu'on est trois minutes
qui avait troqué les quatre c'est
possible ça peut être jouée d'un instant
à l'autre parler comme ça y est c'est
fait il l'a fait judith va reprendre du
pied mais que la reprise d'atours plus
en plus influents plus pour michael
adams à noter que ces deux et à quatre
sont en prise
robert c'est important mais l'ordinateur
annonce net avantage pour michael et oui
puisque le pion aux 4 n'est pas vraiment
pris si on prend il ya des mecs cartes
et des magistrats ce que de se passer
c'est qu'elle va donner la qualité et
perdre perdre la finale
tout à fait la menace positionnelle de
michael adams de jeu mais ces deux c4 se
fout on s'est tu es trop fort comme tu
l'as dit robert il va falloir donner la
qualité au niveau du temps il reste un
peu moins de trois minutes à michael
adams est un peu moins de trois minutes
à judith donc égalité coup pour coup
comme d'habitude coup pour coup mais la
position se détériorer alors qu'on est
au 28e coup 28e produits sont donc très
très loin des ajouts de temps on voit
michael adams ici chez dit paul guerre
qu'il réfléchit on ne sait pas quoi
faire
comment un hacker michael adams ahmad
qu'elle ignore m'accable adjoua justice
pas mal bonne défense en justice une
défense intéressante mais que la donne
soit sans doute joué c4 ou d'un les
flammes d'abord damas quatre c4
j'aime bien ses cartes mois suivi de la
f4 il faut pas donner toujours c'est le
vrai défi car d'abord ça revient au même
c4 est joué par michael adams high mais
là c'est fini c'est de la boucherie
c'est de la boucherie elle peut jouer un
rôle
cette visite faisait 6 non non non elle
va jouer trois sets out
c'est probable
c'est le coût attendu de judit polgar
non qu'est-ce qu'elle a joués qu'est ce
que la jouer ici en bessin à l'aisselle
enfume conseil et ça y est c'est la
tentative d'en fumer et ne lâche pas
l'affairé
judit polgar mais que l'homme se
reprendre du pied droit et ensuite tous
et c5
c'est la réaction normale la réaction
intuitif que ferait n'importe quel
joueur moyen michael adams n'est pas un
joueur brillant c'est un top et donc il
va peut-être trouver autre chose
wen ont ils appris je crois voilà il a
ramassé il ramassait les pions il est
repassé les pions c'est un qui la
rachète a été jouée pour h7 judit polgar
se prémunit et donc il reste tellement
peu de temps que nous allons passer sur
l'échiquier réelle des joueurs
voilà pour ces deux a été jouée par
judit polgar ils à tours qui descend
lentement pour ces deux très très chaud
extrêmement chaud
après 2004 de michael adams j'ai dû tout
le gard jet tours ces deux vraiment
c'est une position complexe elle n'a pas
l'air bien judit polgar elle n'a pas
l'air bien non et michael peut aussi
jouer h4 essayer de la mater sauvagement
tuée sauvagement tout romain mais
qu'elle n'a pas un sauvage des anglais
un plot dame habite chez nos amis lui en
religion sur vos cartes s'allier c'est
désormais un peu de jeu 1
c'est effrayant c'est effrayant j'ai dit
paul garde trouve des trucs h4 ça y est
michael on voit obligée de paul dirac
sommes très très mal mais elle a réussi
à replacer ses pièces comme d'habitude
bilan pendule une 40 pour les deux
joueurs 34 locale au visage et le cou 17
des 5
ouais mais d7 d5 il y aura que 4 504 5
qui ont fait 1 complètement fou je ne
sais pas ce que peut jouer judith dans
la main de son amas de essayer de voile
à damas cinq attaques à tout même à 5 et
la kfw journée michael je ne sais pas
peut-être fou pékin sait qu'il est
gagnant mais il faut être précis
et oui il lui reste une minute trente
une minute trente pour jouer 15 coups b4
tout simplement avant les agrémentant
clinquart ne s'est pas mal mais qu'adam
35 peut-être oui peut-être je vais
tomber quatre mécanos d'homme ça me
semblait sais quel avantage c'est que ça
protège latéralement le b15 h5 d'emprunt
b5 ses films
elle en fut mais elle en fut un non mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe robert sur dame b
vite
c'est la question à 8,8 à fouetter fuite
c'est ça le truc m'a nasdaq prend 1,6
judit polgar rem a juste un match dans
le match 5 forcé et de l'as pas vu pour
l'instant judit polgar elle ne l'a pas
vu et pourtant c'est le seul coup il
faut qu'elle le joug on l a pas vu si l
a pas vu sa croissance elle ne voit pas
et bien si l affût calendrier des
matches c'est tout à fait le seul coup
mais il y à tout reprendre et 7 quand
même alors qu'il reste une minute à
michael adams contre une minute à judith
sans ambages de très vite envie de
gagner tout simplement tout reprend 17 à
l'air très très fort je crois qu'il va
le faire michael non ranger un chien
c'est dans le coup c'est des coups
hallucinogènes qu'est ce qui se passe
dans la jolie plus des 5,5 au 5 tours 2
non non la tournée pas les redevances c4
c'est beaucoup plus fort elle joue bien
judit polgar dans cette position
peut-être que quelque part des sont fous
ces 5 voilà c'est fait six ou sept fous
c'est simple c'est bien joué je suis dit
rodez sans la tour on sait d'eux il faut
maintenant passer par derrière avec tour
un peu terne f3 damev 3 et wii échange
les dames c'est georges dooghe ces
techniques pour produire ou 5 il a pas
vu ça michael tourcoing tours et oui
alors que l'ordinateur dit que c'est
égal complètement égal je dis tu as
gagné
judith a gagné elle a maté michael adams
comment elle a maté michael adams damon
un math à un incroyable complètement
incroyable à la cornouaille tragique
pour michael complètement incroyable ce
café judit polgar en la sv s'est passé
horrible c'est horrible ce qui est
arrivé à madrid as complètement gagnant
toute la partie et il a fini par se
faire planter d'un but un match vraiment
vraiment c'était du très très beau jeu
de judit polgar qui prouve une fois de
plus c'était facile
s'échapper des poubelles n'est plus
horrible non mais c'était vraiment perdu
mais elle a gagné elle se qualifie c'est
incroyable et elle jouera kasparov
demain judit polgar est-ce que leurs
escales arrivera en fumée kasparov de la
même façon eh ben tu connais ma réponse
stéphane non la réponse est non alors
que nous avons maintenant à l'élément
michaud qui grille choqué gagnant riccio
contre gourevitch ans non c'est pas vrai
il va nous faire venir pour les
départage fantastique fantastic sigrid
choc revient avec des gagnants de
l'autre choc rôle à la crise ou et
gagnant ça y est c'est sûr il va gagner
cette position avait tchouk rose 5 mihai
gourévitch n'a pas réussi natar réussi à
s'en sortir
incroyable qu adam s'est perdue cette
partie incroyable c'est affreux c'est
affreux
c'était pas si c'est un plus mais ce que
je disais c'était si simple à jouer
et oui voilà la position je ne sais pas
s'ils abandonnent de toute façon
gourévitch gourévitch a abandonné donc
des partages great chocovic ce soir 22h
donc les qualifier de cette première
journée stéphane m'bia kasparov qui
jouera demain contre pôle gare ouais bah
relief qui n'ont kasparov bas relief qui
jouera contre pôle gare et kasparov qui
jouera contre gourévitch ou gris tchouk
oui et oui le vainqueur du départage de
ce soir vainqueur du temps ramené vous
avait ce soir à 21h55 états unis en
direct du palais des festivals de cannes
on vous remercie d'avoir suivi cette
émission est vraiment c'était du très
beau spectacle
à bientôt